now it is time for me to put on my smart
glasses and mop the sweat off my brow
and read the final thought if prosperity
preachers like Joel Osteen encourage you
to do better for yourself there doesn't
seem to me anything particularly wrong
with that within that narrow scope that
Osteen sets for himself
perhaps his message can encourage people
if so go with God
the worry is that people might take him
for something that he himself admits
that he's not in the weight of glory CS
Lewis describes heresy not as the
promotion of Vice over virtue but rather
as the promotion of some particular
virtue over all the others charity to
the exclusion of prudence justice to the
exclusion of charity the power of
positive thinking is neither a
theological nor a cardinal virtue and it
shouldn't be confused for one lest
another Lewis admonition creep up on you
he warns if you look for truth you may
find comfort in the end if you look for
comfort you will not get either comfort
or truth only soft soap and wishful
thinking to begin and in the end despair
on that despairing note I am Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Nolt show
come back tomorrow and we'll give you
hope
[Music]
you
[Music]